you recently went down I think did you
go down to their studio I really chat
down it respawn yep cool yeah and you
got to pretty much see you saw some
single player which we can't talk about
I don't think correct yeah I actually
got to play a pretty substantial portion
of like the complete campaign but yeah
that is still embargoed until a little
later this week so check back on I don't
know if I can allowed to say the embargo
but ya later this week will say maybe
around Thursday keep refreshing the game
so I home yeah never start over yeah
yeah just for the rest you just exactly
just have your phone at all times just
walk and fresh so so we saw Rob and I
have gone to play a lot of it too we did
a preview series on it kind of like two
part series on how this is kind of like
they're trying to correct mistakes they
made with the first time fall but also
like how this is becoming almost like a
hero shooter in my view of how like the
Titans are designed and how it becomes
like you can see a Titan signature moves
and you can see you know like how to
counteract them and they can see yours
it's kind of like a chess match almost
at that point but you got to see all 6
Titans finally yeah yeah and actually
got to play all 6 as well so it wasn't
just like here's a trailer because they
put trailers up a couple weeks ago to
kind of vaguely introduce what each of
the new Titans does but yeah so the
multiplayer you have choice of any of
the six Titans and and yeah I mean I
wouldn't necessarily call like a hero
shooter more maybe like a class space
shooter because each of the titans does
seem to kind of represent a different
class in a way at least if you go judge
them according to their primary weapons
like for example Ronan has a shotgun and
a sword like those are his primary
weapons so he's clearly at the up-close
damage dealer he's that kind of tank
type a phase shift to write that can get
a shift is really cool um yeah like oh
so pilots have a cloak ability but this
is not that this is a different thing
basically like you just blink out of
existence entirely like you don't even
have a shadow that people can track like
you're just simply not there so you
can't be damaged you can't be seen it
only lasts a few seconds though and when
you're in that state you actually can't
see your opponent's you just see like a
black and white kind of version of the
world and can maneuver so it's useful
for a couple reasons like my favorite
was to just charge straight at people
and as soon as that kind of like got me
in their site I would blink out of
existence and continue to rush at them
in like the parallel dimension and then
when I snapped back into reality I was
suddenly like right in their face a
sword in shock exactly
so that was really fun and really
awesome but then in contrast to someone
like North Star I think Rob's a big fan
of and that character that characters
based weapon is essentially a sniper
rifle like the exact opposite where you
want to play the spacing game you want
to hang back and it not only is it it's
a railgun so it charges up over time so
you really can't be in people's face
with that character you have to hang
back you have to bide your time so yeah
my mind is just kind of class based you
have a tank you have a sniper you have
the shotgun run and gun early all these
different types and and play styles so
whatever you're into there's probably a
Titan that'll loosely fit what you want
to get out of the game yeah and then
like North Star just to back track quick
leaves that the one that has a kind of
Farah justice from above reigns from
above totally yeah as you mentioned so
each of the titans has sort of an ultra
ability and like once so over the course
of around as you like accumulate damage
and do other things to contribute to
your team you eventually unlock their
ultra and yes so in North Stars case
it's essentially like a ferret death
from above like VTOL hover plus like
homing missile barrage it's pretty
awe-inspiring is it referred to as an
ultra I don't honestly like I'm trying
to remember so each Titan has a core of
like ok they're described as the sword
core let's stop latching on to new terms
this is a class-based thing like you
said which I'm happy about this is not
here o Shah lyric when the class pays
you build up existing throw match these
are it's an all this like okay if you
can / reference only go back to another
cannon out of your chest and shoot a
laser out of it well which that's not
that's not altima I would cut some more
ability that's a core ability alright
anyway let's go to limit bring me before
overwatch no but it's now but it's not
going to like early street fighter like
a dota term Jax tech I don't know so
when MOBAs were invented than we and now
um but today I believe they're called
core ability that just nah eze so nobody
knows what that means outside of this
context though like if we sit and
explain to a quality or call it a super
okay just sounds like they have really
nice naps Titan has a super yeah they
all sit on those stupid balls all day is
really works their midsection and
they'll get really taught abs look for
the hot calendar coming out next year
cool rolla real sexy do you have like a
favorite Titan because
you said there was one that's kind of
like just to piss peed off i'm gonna use
another overwatch you did say there's
like a soldier 76 and like Call of Duty
like kind of everyman Carrick tighten
that like anybody this played a shooter
we'll get ya so one of the titans I'm
trying to member if it's a legion or
tone I believe its Legion has a sort of
mini gun and a really good all-around
mix it like health damage and speed so
they that that particular character is
you know just sort of eat well-balanced
equally yummy it just doesn't serve as
deep anish purpose is something like
North Star who really has to hang back
or someone like Ronin who really has to
be up close and so it'd be effective the
minigun is like has an up-close switch
or like you can change its firing mode
sorry to backtrack you can change its
firing mode so you can fire either like
a steady stream of bullets or a wider
spray so he's useful from a variety of
different ranges he again has a strong
movement and health so you can kind of
play him as more of the standard mid mid
range shooter character it'll be a good
i think intro for people because
everybody immediately understands how a
minigun works right like it charges up
you fire a bunch of bullets thanks in
front you die even that character super
is like an amped-up version it's really
nothing to differently you just fire
slightly more powerful bullets so it's
not like oh you take off in a raining
bullets or no you face shift out of
existence it's 0 your bullets are just
more powerful so again really easy to
understand really like low barrier to
entry for that particular character but
still totally fun to play cuz again who
doesn't love a minigun and just like
completely shredding everything in the
environment yeah did you have a favorite
Titan III really like Ronan I just found
it really satisfying to get in people's
faces Ronan fortune has very limited
health though so I would generally like
get up close take down one Titan and
then be it basically at the point of
death but you can still equip a nuclear
eject which people may remember from the
previous game so we pronounced nucular
nuclear eject I'm pretty sure it's the
with foliage in the library um what was
I going with this oh really don't have
scissors like a derailment heavy episode
today um the hell are they talking about
Rosie overall oh yeah you can love you
blow up and take people down with you
it's awesome so doesn't matter you have
very little health because as soon as
you die you explode and
oh cool again ok ok cool so how does it
feel overall these field balances the
flow the multiplayer still feel intact
with six people instead of just the two
we've seen so far yeah well actually so
um uh to me it feels way more complete
and way more interesting than the beta
did the beta obviously was missing a lot
of content I mean you'll hit two two of
the six titans but also there were a
bunch of missing maps and a bit i'm a
bunch of missing pilot ability so i
wanted to talk about that as well
because the game is more than just
heightens obviously and i know a lot of
people that i've spoken to about the
beta came away thinking like aw man why
would you ever play with anything but
the grappling hook the grappling hook
kind of changes the game completely for
pilots it's you know suddenly wall
running your freerunning is no longer as
essential as it was but on some of the
new maps i found that the grappling hook
wasn't even that useful in a way like
there's a really dense new map called
Eden where I found that it was dense
enough there were enough objects to sort
of wall jump off of that I was able to
make my way through the city and keep my
momentum up without ever relying on the
grappling hook which meant that I could
use that skill slot on something else
and there are other abilities that are
actually like appealing and useful some
more than others those I was sticking to
that like sonar pulse knife I really
like well that maybe that's just comes
from like my background and just
shooters in general like knowing where
people are is obviously a huge deal yeah
I think I was just more comfortable with
that it's like I could rely on the
really fine-tuned wall traversal and
white wall runs and Mike vaults and I
didn't have to worry about the grappling
hook yeah where's the knife I could just
throw stand still see if anybody's above
me below me around me or just on the run
you see if any ways about to ambush me I
don't know I didn't think the grappling
hook was huge of a deals a lot of people
did it's cool it's fun but and I feel I
think it feels great but I wasn't like
one of those people that was you know
kind of you know like you said being
attached to it yeah I'm executor with
you attached to it grapple that's good
um yeah there's certain maps where makes
a lot of sense Peter shakings I don't
know if he was on camera right there but
that's the correct reaction Peter um
yeah there are certain maps were makes a
lot of sense because the maps now I I
would argue have more verticality than
the maps did in the first game so if you
are down like deep in a trench and
you're trying to get to the top of a
building and there's like a large
scalable section you may not be able to
wall jump your way up that but the
grappling hook can save you much time
boom hey use can suddenly traverse a
section of the level that other pilots
yeah very useful but not every map has
that so that like I said there are
plenty of situations where the grappling
hook is going to be less useful than
other skills here so I think once people
get a chance to play all of the content
together and see how it all fits
together and see how all the different
tactics complement one another their
realize that it's a bit more of a
complete product then the beta was and I
don't know that it made it I'm not
guaranteeing that everybody who hated
the beta is actually gonna love the full
game people might still hate it but I
personally enjoyed what I was able to
play last week much more than I enjoyed
the beta in large part because there's
so much more going on and there's so
much more strategy and if you see the
other team is using certain types of
titans you can pick a Titan to give
yourself an advantage over that type
because you can switch between deaths
and just that ability to switch on the
fly and adjust your tactics and change
all this stuff and having all these
options really makes the game kind of
more rich but all these essential stuff
is there there's still mech battles
there's still wall running and you know
all that kind of stuff it's still
titanfall to me even if certain things
have changed but yeah I mean I had a lot
of fun with it I really enjoyed my time
cool so you got your full like preview
stuff up on gamespot your single-player
stuff is coming later this week and
we'll be able to talk more about how the
Titans work there and how the story is
unfolding and whatnot full profile and
all the Titans went up last week people
should definitely go check that out Rob
handlery did an amazing job editing
together a video conversation we had and
you have single-player stuff going up
later this week bronze in the room
that's why I insulted him cool hey there
is okay so that's titanfall 2 like Scott
saw he's got his content up on the site
right now we have single-player stuff
coming later this week and that releases
October 28 for ps4 xbox one and we can
see how it like the beta was indicative
of the game then npc NPC sorry forgot
that one